with a choice between risking their
health and casting their votes
tens of thousands of Wisconsinites
arrived at the polls I'd rather wait in
this line hand in hand come together as
an American - coming exercises great
god-given freedom right to vote they
came with masks gloves and an abiding
faith in democracy and a rising furor
for the leaders who put them at risk by
compelling them to carry out an election
amid a deadly global pandemic it was an
election marked by uncertainty and chaos
it is a complete mess here in the City
of Milwaukee where there are more than
300,000 registered voters there are only
five polling places there are usually a
hundred and eighty voters stood two
metres apart in lines that stretched for
blocks the election should have been
postponed no doubt there's no question
the on-again-off-again election began
after a 24 hour whirlwind of judicial
action on Monday that began with a
Democratic governor Tony Evers calling
the election off I cannot in good
conscience allow any types of gathering
that would further the spread of this
disease and to put more lives at risk
Wisconsin's conservative state Supreme
Court called it back on again saying
eva's had overstepped his authority then
the conservative US Supreme Court
weighed in overturning a lower court
ruling that would have extended mail-in
voting until April 13th the mail ballots
are corrupt in my opinion and they
collect them and they get people to go
in and sign them and then they've
they're forgeries in many cases it's a
horrible thing now all votes must be
postmarked by Tuesday or not counted at
all the chaotic election in the middle
of a global pandemic could leave
hundreds of thousands of votes on
tallied about 1.3 million people asked
for a mail-in ballot but by early
Tuesday fewer than 900,000 had actually
gotten one in many said they simply
didn't arrive in time a hundred cities
and towns couldn't persuade enough poll
workers to open a single voting site so
the governor called in the Army National
Guard to do their work
voters vented their fury II
they braved the virus to go to the polls
and vote John hendren al-jazeera Chicago